17h26 ce samedi edouard philippe
s'avance à la tribune devant les rangs
clairsemés de l'assemblée nationale à
l'issue d'une nouvelle suspension de
séance
il annonce alors ce que l'opposition
redoute depuis plusieurs jours
conformément à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution de 1958 et après en
avoir obtenu l'autorisation du conseil
des ministres du 29 février
j'ai décidé d'engager la responsabilité
du gouvernement sur le projet de loi
instituant un système universel de
retraite non pour mettre fin au débat
mais pour mettre fin à cet épisode de
non débat à un parlement privé de sa
fonction éminente de faire la loi et
pour permettre à la suite du processus
législatif de s'engager
une déclaration qui prend les députés
par surprise y compris ceux de la
majorité
selon le quotidien le monde la plupart
des élus et les rues même qu'ils ne se
trouvent pas en séance apprennent la
nouvelle à la radio ou sur leur
smartphone alors que la tension monte
dans le pays en raison de l'épidémie de
coronavirus l'annnonce de l'exécutif a
fait l'effet d'une bombe
certains parlementaires appartenant au
parti présidentiel sont sidérés c'est
une incompréhensible erreur politique
stratégique et institutionnels deux
motions de censure ont été déposés par
l'opposition
la première provient des républicains
l'autre est porté par une alliance entre
insoumis communistes et socialistes
d'émotion qui ont toutefois très peu de
chances d'aboutir
pour être validée et renverser le
gouvernement il faut obtenir une
majorité absolue au sein de l'assemblée
nationale située à 2 189 députés
or malgré les exclusions et autres
départs la majorité présidentielle
dispose toujours de 299 sièges auxquels
il faut rajouter
sauf surprise les 46 députés modem
depuis 1958 c'est la 89e fois qu'un
gouvernement engage sa responsabilité
via le 49-3 quant aux motions de censure
elles n'ont quasiment jamais abouti
dans toute l'histoire de la vème
république une seule a été adoptée par
l'assemblée
c'était en 1962 contre le gouvernement
de georges pompidou il y a donc presque
60 ans